Young person you will find in your life
that sometimes your great ambitions will
be momentarily stymied,
forwarded marginalized by those who were
perhaps luckier come from money where
more doors opened,
where college was a given.
It was not a student loan.
It was something that dad paid for.
To wear an ease and confidence in life
was almost a birthright where for you it
was a very hard climb.
Okay?
That happens all the time.
Some of the greatest Americans,
some of the greatest thinkers,
artists,
architects,
politicians and other movers,
shakers and creators all over the world
have come from very meager beginnings
like my favorite American Abraham
Lincoln.
And so just because you come from
nothing,
you must not let that be something that
holds you back and you will encounter
people who never have to pay in full.
They get to wreck the room and never
have to clean it.
They can get all the way through high
school and never understand where a
dollar comes from because they just get
it given to them.
I went to school with guys like that.
You've had presidents like that.
You've had friends like that and you've,
you've suffered,
your humility has been tried.
Your patients has been tried,
your resolve and your ambition has been
tried.
You cannot let these people make you
feel that you have in any way been
dwarfed or outclassed.
You must really go for your own and
realize how short life is.
You got what you got,
so you got to make the most of it.
You really can't spend a whole lot of
time worrying about his,
you really have to go for your own.
If you have an idea of what you want to
do in your future,
you must go at it with almost monastic
obsession.
Be It music,
the ballet or just a basic degree.
You have to go at it singlemindedly and
let nothing get in your way and that's
why you're young.
That's why you can survive on no sleep,
top ramen noodles and dental floss and
still look good and take advantage of
that.
Create energy.
You have the fact that you can do an all
nighter,
all the people you admire from Muhammad
Ali to any politician,
they work and work and work like Bill
Clinton.
Not everyone's favorite rhodes scholar.
He's smart for a reason.
A got a great gift,
great mind.
But he sat and he shoved a whole bunch
information in there and he learned how
to connect the dots.
And so can you,
your president right now is a man who
got where he is through very hard work
and scholarships,
mainly hard work and application and
discipline.
If these people can do it,
why not you?
It is very,
very easy though to feel smaller,
to feel less than when you see sue,
see people with an advantage
walk where you struggle,
who have ease of motion,
where you are constricted.
It can be a real shot to your morale.
Like it can be flummoxing to a degree
where you're almost paralytic.
You got to keep picking yourself up and
reaching for it.
And that's the long and short of it.
Cause if you don't,
it won't get done.